i just bought three books on boredom
the other day uh so now i'm really
interested in this topic because i was
anxious about my book launch
happening this week so i was like okay i
need something else so i have this idea
for a
i might do as an article first but as a
book like okay i need something cool
to be thinking about because i was
worried about like i don't know oh yeah
is the launch going to work the pandemic
what's going to happen i don't know if
it's going to get there so i
this is exactly what we're talking about
so i went out and i bought a bunch of
books
and i'm beginning like a whole sort of
intellectual exploration
well i think that's one of the profound
ideas and deep work
that you don't expand on too much is uh
boredom yeah well so deep work had a
superficial idea
about boredom which which was i had this
chapter called embrace boredom
and a very functionalist idea was
basically
you have to have some boredom in your
regular schedule or your mind is going
to form a pavlovian connection
between as soon as i feel boredom i get
stimuli
and once it forms that connection it's
never going to tolerate deep work so
there's this very
pragmatic treatment of boredom of your
mind better be used to the idea that
sometimes you don't get stimuli because
otherwise you can't
write for three hours like it's just not
going to tolerate it but more
more recently what i'm really interested
in boredom is it as a fundamental human
drive
right because it's incredibly
uncomfortable and think about the other
things that are incredibly uncomfortable
like hunger or thirst
they serve a really important purpose
for a species right like if something is
really distressing there's a reason pain
is really uncomfortable because we need
to
worry about getting injured thirst is
really uncomfortable because we need
water to survive
so what's boredom why is that
uncomfortable
and and i've been interested in this
notion that
boredom is about driving us towards
productive action like as a species i
mean think about it like what
what got us to actually take advantage
of these brains what got us to actually
work with fire what got us to start
shaping stones and the hand axes and
figuring out if we could actually
sharpen a stick
sharp enough that we could throw it as a
melee weapon or a distance weapon for
hunting mammoth right
boredom drives us towards action so now
i'm fascinated by this fundamental
action
instinct uh because i have this theory
that i'm working on
that we're out of sync with it just like
we got we have this drive for hunger but
then we introduced junk food and got out
of sync with hunger and it makes us
really unhealthy
we have this drive towards action but
then we we overload ourselves and we
have all of these distractions and then
that causes
uh it's like a cognitive action obesity
type thing because it short-circuits
this system that wants us to do things
but we put more things in our plate than
we can possibly do and then we're really
frustrated we can't do them
and we're short-circuiting all of our
wires so it all comes back to this
question
well what would be the ideal the ideal
sort of amount of stuff to do and type
of things to do like if we wanted to
look back at our ancestral environment
and say if i could just build from
scratch
what type how much work i do and what i
work on to be as in touch with that as
like paleo people are trying to get
their diets in touch with that and so
now i'm just
let's see this is i'm just it's
something i made up yeah but now i'm
going deep on it and one of my podcast
listeners i was talking about on the
show and
i was like well i kept trying to learn
about animals and boredom and she sent
me this cool article from
an animal behaviorless journal about
what we know about human boredom versus
animal boredom
so trying to figure out that puzzle is
uh
the wave that's high so i can get
through the wave that's low of like i
don't know about this pandemic book
launch and yeah
and my research my research is stumbling
a little bit because of the pandemic and
so i needed a nice you know high so
there we go there's a case study
well the is both a case study and a very
interesting set of concepts because i
didn't even realize that
it's so simple i'm one of the people
that
uh has a interesting push and pull
dynamic with hunger trying to understand
the
hunger with myself like i probably have
an unhealthy relationship with food
i don't know but there's probably
probably a perfect
that's a nice way to think about diet as
action
there's probably an optimal risk diet
response
to the the experience that our body's
telling us the signal that a body's
sending which is hunger
and in that same way boredom is sending
a signal
and most of our intellectual activities
in this world
our creative activities are essentially
a response uh
to that signal yeah and think about this
analogy that we have this hunger
instinct that
junk food short circuits yes right it's
like oh we'll we'll
satisfy that hyperpalatably and it
doesn't end up well
now think about modern attention
engineered
digitally mediated entertainment we have
this board of instinct
oh we can we can take care of that with
a hyperpalatable
alternative is that going to lead to a
similar problem so i've been
fasting a lot lately like i'm doing
eating once a day i've been doing that
for over a month
just eating one meal a day and primarily
meat
but it's very fasting has been
incredible
for me for focus for well-being for a
few
i don't i don't know just for feeling
good okay we'll put on a chart what
makes me feel good
and uh that fasting and eating primarily
meat-based diet
makes me feel really good and so
but that ultimately what fasting did
i haven't fasted super long yet like a
seven day diet which i really like to do
but even just fasting for a day for 24
hours
gets you in touch with your with this
signal
it's fascinating like you get to listen
to your you learn to listen to your body
that like you know it's okay to be
hungry
it's like a little signal that sends you
stuff and then and then uh
i get to listen to how it responds when
i
put food in my body like and i get to
like
okay cool so like food is the thing
that pacifies the signal like it sounds
ridiculous okay
you could do that with and do different
types of food it feels different so you
learn about what your body
wants for some reason fasting
it's similar to the deport embrace
boredom
fasting allowed me to go into mode of
listening of trying to understand the
signal
that i could say i have an unhealthy
appreciation of fruit okay i love apples
and cherries
like i don't know how to moderate them
so if you take just same amount of
calories i don't know
calories matter but they say calories 2
000 calories of cherries
versus 2 000 calories of steak
if i eat 2 000 calories of steak maybe
just a little bit of like green beans or
cauliflower
i'm going to feel really good fulfilled
focused and happy yeah if i eat cherries
i'm going to be
i'm going to wake up behind a dumpster
crying with like
naked and like it's just it's all around
yeah
with everything yeah and just like
bloated
just not and unhappy and also
the mood swings up and down i don't know
uh and i'll be much hungrier the next
day
uh sometimes it takes a couple days but
when i introduce carbs into the system
too many carbs i it starts
it's just unhealthy i go into this
roller coaster as opposed to a calm boat
ride along the river
in the amazon or something like that
yeah so fasting was the mechanism
of for me to start listening to the body
i wonder if you can do that same kind i
guess that's what meditation a little
bit is a little bit but
yeah listen to boredom
you